hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb ben b and today I'm gonna
be taking you through another game from
the world rapid championship that just
took place in Russia at the end of 2019
so this is gonna be a game from Magnus
Carlsen who of course won the world
rapid championship this year he actually
went home a double champion winning both
the rapid and the blitz portions and
today I wanted to take a look at a game
that you're not gonna see too often
this is Magnus Carlsen against Victor
lesney qey who is a 26 50 level
Grandmaster and I find these games
really interesting to look at because of
course
26:50 grandmasters are very very strong
professional chess players and the way
that Magnus and other top top level GM's
can pick them apart it is very
interesting to see so why don't we take
a look and see what happened here Magnus
played d4 d5 Knight f3 Knight f6 Bishop
f4 Bishop f5 III e 6 perhaps some
beginners out there will recognize this
style of opening where one player just
simply copies the other but after Knight
bTW 2 we do see a deviation with Bishop
e7 and now there is some imbalance to
the game this is a pretty uncommon
opening actually this isn't one that
you'll see too often but what I wanted
to talk about with opening especially
the next few moves we see 95o
slightly strange h5 move from black
although it does make some sense Bishop
d3 you'll see that Magnus isn't afraid
to trade pieces in the opening and I
think this just should be a lesson to
take away when you at home are are
playing a slightly weaker player you
know just because there are fewer pieces
on the board doesn't mean you'll not
have any chances to win the game if
Magnus can be a 2650 Grandmaster after
trading off a few pieces you can be it
in 1800 if you're if you're a 1,900
level player so we see this trade occur
Knight bd7
Queen e2 and this Knight comes to 8
Knight comes to e4 CH 3 we see yet
another trade now after Bishop d6 man
this not hesitant to trade a doll takes
again and actually castles queenside so
this is the type of position that you
might think would be kind of difficult
to try and generate some winning chances
black does have double punts
however they are strong center pawns
flex going to simply push in the center
you might think well there's a half-open
C file but I'm not sure how either side
can really make use of it there's not
much to play for it looks like so let's
see what Magnus really does to generate
these chances here he starts with the
move or black starts with the move H for
locking down these pawns on the Kings
side we see King b1 from white black
maneuvers this Knight back towards this
efore square Magnus does not give them
the chance to put it there in place f3
this is an interesting move to talk
about as well f3 you might be hearing
some alarm bells right Black has pushed
this pawn to h4 creating an outpost on
g3 and you might have heard of the power
of Knights on the 6th rank or in this
case the 3rd rank but really a knight on
G 3 would just be out of play here you
see this sometimes while a night on e 3
or D 3 would be very very powerful for
black and night on G's theory simply
isn't really hitting any relevant
squares you force this rook to move this
short comes to a better Square and then
what is your knight really doing there
so Agnes not hesitant at all to prevent
the knight from coming to the much
better e4 square black plays Queen b6 we
see York H e1 and now black also chooses
to Castle queenside once again this is
the it's very funny to see this is the
type of chess you see between a lower
rated player at the class level playing
somebody 200 points higher rated than
them you know it's like okay let's let's
trade pieces let's castle on the same
side let's just get to the most equal
position I can and hopefully I won't
lose and the fact of the matter is when
you play chess like that the stronger
player usually has enough room to to
prove that he is in fact stronger the
style of chess I've always preferred
been playing a higher in a player is to
go for complications go for the type of
position that's so complicated that
neither of you can really work work
everything out and then you'll both have
chances to win the game
because in positions like this you
really just allowed Magnus to do his
thing and outplay you you started with
c3 which is kind of interesting
King b8 and now II for Magnus does in
fact break in the center this is the
point of c3 to defend the d4 pawn and
allow for this break after Queen c7 -
brings this queen out to g5 just poking
just poking at the black camp looking at
g7 looking at h4 looking at d5 black
defends this pawn but is diverting a lot
of his pieces to the Kings side now we
see rook c1 for Magnus one of those
mysterious rook moves perhaps but it's
actually not so mysterious
Magnus technically has a majority on the
Queen side and that's the plan he had
kind of developed at this point
eventually he's gonna want to push these
pawn for it pawns forward attack the
black King and use this majority to his
advantage we see rook h5 and I'm very
much don't like this move from from
black you're committing this rook solely
to the Kings side it's not going to take
you at least two moves to come back to
the defense of your king and I don't
know for certain what the point of
having this irken h5 is perhaps you are
worried about this Queen being over here
but it's just not it doesn't feel quite
right to me we see a queen e3 and now e5
is probably the point of blacks play
with the support of the rook you can
break in the center but after D takes e5
in D takes e5 we see this move c4 from
Magnus and already things are starting
to look a little bit uncomfortable that
perfectly balanced level position where
you know each side has a knight each
side as Castle queenside is starting to
look slightly imbalanced and it's
starting to look imbalanced in White's
favor and this is how the stronger
player usually ends up winning he
creates an imbalance somewhere and then
uses it to his advantage to win the game
black could have considered capturing
this pawn white likely would have
continued with Knight c5 and for one you
can consider trying to take this back
immediately but probably you would run
in
a tactic here with b6 so you do have to
be slightly careful but Magnus might
have been considering sacrificing this
pawn and then using this open file to
his advantage bringing the rooks into
the game and now you really see why I
don't like this rook on on age five it's
really causing problems
black would love to play the move rook
c8 here if this rook were on h8 - to
support this king but the rook simply
isn't there so white is going to have
pressure on the C file and while black
is up a full pawn for it it's definite
compensation for a white so perhaps
because he was afraid of this line
afraid of Magnus he plays d4 trying to
keep things closed but this is actually
quite good for white now the reason
being a knight is ideally placed on d3
blockading this d4 pawn and now we have
free reign to run these pawns up the
board with a definite majority and
that's exactly what happens
Knight d7 we see c5 this trick comes to
h6 now looking to come back over but
after b4 Queen c6 Queen B - Queen B 5
Queen b3 continues to support these
breaks the rook comes to a6 of course
you know black doing everything he can
to prevent this this pawn a4 from coming
white simply brings the knight back to
b2 and it will be coming through to
devastating effect the rook now on a6 is
doing nothing as a for comes anyways so
the wreck has to move again to f6 now
after a for Queen c6 the the end is
coming quite quite quickly very very
natural chess for Magnus he just pushes
his pawns and the black King suffers
Queen B for not of course trading the
Queen's the skirt comes to c8 and you
really see how Magnus has just
completely discord innate appeases it's
it's the type of position you just you
hate to look at c6 Knight b6 a
five-night a8 disgusting C takes b7 King
takes b7 we see a trade and now this
rook is locked out of play
by these very powerful
as well as this Queen this Knight is
stuck on the a8 square this queen is
getting harassed and after queen d8
white simply brings his last piece envy
attack and checkmate is is coming we see
night c7 but it's too little too late
night c5 check King it and now this pawn
breaks through taking away the final
defenders in front of the black king and
checkmating after all a takes b6 it
takes b6 night a6 you could actually
capture this piece there is a rook takes
b6 to look out for but due to a couple
different moves rook c8 in particular it
would be up a piece but Magnus sees
better he plays b7 check and after King
a seven-night takes a 6 here and now the
threat of b8 is preventing rook b6 so we
see rook takes a 6 and the final move of
the game is rook c8 and black resigns
there's simply no way to prevent b8
Queen with with the checkmate and so
this is as simple as chess gets at the
top level Magnus but his opponent do do
what he wanted to do he said okay you
want to trade off some pieces we can
trade off some pieces I'm just gonna
keep my chances alive he pushed on the
Kings side and was nikka got checkmated
quite quite quickly and quite
devastatingly well thank you very much
for joining me again for game review
mining my name is Caleb Denby and I will
see you in the next episode